did watching all the episodes change the
way you felt it didn't change the way
that I felt but I was kind of drawn in
like everyone else to the story that was
presented and the parts that were the
most meaningful between Kevin and I were
things that were off-camera like any
opportunity he could talk to me and make
that connection with me that none of the
other guys did the truth is that I I did
choose Kevin for a reason I'm really
thankful that people have been so
understanding about that some people not
so much but mostly people have
understood that we just need a little
bit of time you know that after that
happens though when there's no tweeting
there's no pictures together there's no
anything we assume it's over I didn't
think I was going to take it so hard
negative like negativity from social
media and because I'm just a regular guy
I just I went on the show I happen to
meet the girl of my dreams maybe nervous
there was so much more than went on
between us that no one saw saying
terrible things about you and your and
your decision Oh like yeah it's crazy to
me who got it worse on social media I
can take it though I I felt worse for
her because she chose me she doesn't
deserve to be ripped apart for it I
understand that if you don't like the
way I look or the way I talk and
everyone like the way I talk Ross
project but like an evolutionary project
where he has like a missing link sort of
caveman thing to him and he's not really
processing anything hold on a second I
didn't say I didn't like the way I was
trying to watch the election how much I
talked her beside of I though have you
thank you so much guys they really
appreciate it right on thank you very
good don't watch me